je demande un geste je te demande un
geste de compréhension et par un
discours cynique ou à chaque fois que
quelqu'un fait un pas les autres disent
c'est pas mal mais on voudrait plus bon
et on voudrait tout simplement
évidemment votre texte met totalement
dénaturé s'est passé c'est pas
raisonnable c'est pas comme ça ils
savent très bien quelque part alors que
qu'on ne peut pas avancer sur ce terrain
là c'est pas c'est pas crédible que ce
gouvernement qui est qui s'est orienté
sur l'article 2 c'est-à-dire la
négociation dans l'entreprise
c'est ce qui a permis de sauver excusez
moi mais des entreprises comme stx comme
psa c'est des milliers d'emplois
industriels qui ont été sauvés par des
négociations d'entreprise qui sont
d'ailleurs signé notamment par la cgt
gardez donc que vous excluez jean marie
le guen un geste notamment sur les
heures supplémentaires c'est ce que
demandent les frondeurs aujourd'hui
écouter les fondeurs demande toujours
l'abandon complet on pourrait négocier
sur les heures supplémentaires est exclu
et un amendement qu'ils n'y a pas de
sens que de vouloir limiter le champ de
la négociation sur des sujets qui sont
des sujets stratégiques qui permet de
réactiver donc vous restez fermes le
canal de communication est assez étroit
si l'issue est un toussaint pas faire
nous allons était ouvert depuis des
semaines maintenant ça suffit on a fait
à cette bien coûter on a fait tout un
tas de pas ils ont même été contraints
les uns les autres
oui alors maintenant s'il ya une posture
idéologique consiste à vouloir s'opposer
pour s'opposer
bon ben voila mais qu'on ne nous fasse
pas croire que casser ce que vous pensez
il ya une tendance à penser que à partir
du moment où ce que je regarde c'est
contre un texte initial qui était ce
qu'il était et la position des uns et
des autres qui a bougé qui a bougé le
gouvernement sur plein de points je vais
pas faire la liste ici des points amis
du parti socialiste qui a priori votre
ordi enfin un trailer sincérité en
faisant un parent est ce pas ça
consisterait à dire déjà je ne voterai
pas contre ce texte
non pas que ce qui se passe écoutez nous
verrons bien mais nous avons bien
l'intention de faire aboutir cette loi
était déjà plus ou moins vu puisque le
gouvernement a dit qu'il ne reculerait
pas sur ce texte majeur
ceux qui n'ont pas bougé depuis le début
à savoir un certain nombre un petit
groupe de parlementaires qui préfèrent
voter non avec la droite plutôt que de
voter un texte qui est une réforme
positive pour les salariés j'attends de
savoir si vraiment ils s'ils se rendent
bien compte ici le prendront la
responsabilité de cette décision
dans la discussion nous allons voir il
ya encore il ya un temps du débat
parlementaire
c'est mardi il rendez-vous et mardi on
prévoit une très longue séance à
l'assemblée
parce que des choses verrons bien jouer
les cassandre mais nous verrons bien si
j'estime que jusqu'à présent c'est
largement le groupe socialiste la
commission les rapporteurs le
gouvernement qui ont fait des gestes qui
ont amélioré le texte qui devrait
permettre de franchement de d'avoir une
attitude différente de ce qui est bon
alors maintenant si c'est autre chose
que l'on cherche
alors on cherche justement rien cet
autre robe je pense on voit bien il ya
une idée de contestation radicale
politique - r oui soula des arrière
pensées un peu ridicule oui moi mais
voilà elles sont là parce que sur
justement cette question des primaires
les menaces qui ont été formulés
d'exclusion en cas de motion de censure
évidemment pour les députés socialistes
ou encore les investitures qui se sont
rendus aux tractations en ce moment dans
votre parti est ce qu'elles pèsent selon
vous sur super début de la saison jean
christophe cambadélis est exprimée c'est
le premier secrétaire du parti
socialiste faut de la décence faut être
décent peut pas voter une motion de
censure
oui mais au delà le même de la coupe
bien sûr la cohérence intellectuelle
mais j'allais dire de la décence morale
on peut pour brand et la décence morale
et bien sûr comment voulez-vous que on
puis on puisse imaginer que dans une
formation politique et des gens qui
demandent la démission d'un gouvernement
de cette formation pour quoi faire
s'il y avait une démission il y aurait
des élections s'il y avait des élections
ça donnerait quoi une victoire une
victoire de deux ans donc si vous voulez
en gros on le voit bien d'ailleurs il ya
une certaine gauche alors c'est un état
d'esprit je dis pas qu'il est poussé
jusqu'au bout par tous mais c'est un
état d'esprit on l'a vu par exemple en
espagne
on le voyait une certaine gauche qui
préfèrent faire perdre la gauche et
faire gagner la droite plutôt que de
composer